e
for
uh good evening everyone welcome to this
extraordinary scrutiny panel meeting
this
evening far alarm procedures are if the
fire alarm is activated please vacate
the offices down the main staircase
opposite the lifts in the foyer assemble
in h Square on the green and officers
will assist you and advise you when it's
deemed safe to return to the chamber uh
would everyone please present uh ensure
that your mobile phones are turned to
silent and they're not used to make and
receive calls while the meeting is in
progress uh please note this meeting is
being live streamed for members of the
public and this meeting will
subsequently be broadcast on the
internet uh does anyone intend to film
the
meeting and that's a note and there's no
members of public so we'll move on
uh we did have a member that wanted to
speak on the 20.1 but he's not here so
move on uh item number one on the agenda
apologies for absence I've got councelor
Debo and councelor Wing replaced by
councelor Garner any
more nope okay uh any Declarations of
interest uh yes ch um items three and
four decare an interesting please thank
you Council Patman we note
that uh
item
to I'm to ask you what is the nature of
your declaration uh I have done the
online form uh it's a conflict with my
work okay thank you do you need any more
information than that no that's fine
will need
to okay so they they saying you have to
leave the that's fine okay
thank okay moving on uh item number
three the purchase of five Homes at
Reading Street broadstairs for f
affordable rent I call on Miss Jackson
to introduce the report good evening
Miss Jackson good evening thank you um
Council has recently approved an
accelerated affordable rented housing
development program of at least 400 new
homes to be constructed or acquired by
2027 officers were contacted by Milwood
homes who are required to deliver five
affordable homes as part of their
development at Reading Street in
broadstairs this requirement is set out
in the section 106 obligations for the
development they have been unable to
secure a affordable housing provider
deliver these homes and we have seen
evidence of that the capital cost for
the five homes is 800k and 50k for
Associated costs um on paragraph 2.5 of
your reports that you were to received
there is a slight difference in the cash
flow def deficit from year one It should
read 8.1 with a break year even
in Break Even point in year
13 as the homes have been dis designated
as affordable homes in the planning
consent and section 106 agreement they
have been designed specifically for that
purpose and accordingly are considered
appropriate for the HRA in line with the
needs of households on the council's
register or those living in temporary
accommodation there is a significant
level of Need for one bedg homes as well
as larger family homes the unit sizes
and mix of dwellings are as follows one
one bed flat one two bed flat and three
three bed houses it is proposed that the
new homes are let in accordance with the
council's adopted allocations policy at
affordable
rent that's it thank you okay thank you
uh members any questions for M
Jackson um I'm happy to speak on it if
you'd like me to beforehand but
otherwise would you like to speak now
yeah yeah thank you
chair so tonight members are being asked
to consider and respond to the proposal
going forward to Cabinet regarding the
purchase of five Homes at Reading Street
broadstairs the purchase of these homes
is part of our accelerated housing
delivery strategy ensuring that section
106 homes are delivered and that the
social housing that we are entitled to
as part of developments comes to
fruition and does not disappear when
this is the housing that we need Above
All
Else as this is a revenue strategy it
already been established that the HRA
will benefit from these acquis
positions the capital cost for these
properties is £800,000 with £50,000
provided for Associated costs as Ashley
has said this provides one * one bed
flat one two bed flat and three three
bed
houses very importantly this provides
social housing in an area of thanet that
is often inaccessible for renters
property and rental costs in Broad stads
are significant and acquiring social
rehousing within broad stairs is often
challenging in uring that all of our AIS
is accessible to Residents is incredibly
important and local individuals and
families should be able to remain where
their local connections are Acquisitions
such as this support that
aim thank you to Ashley for her work
relating to this proposal in an ever
increasing property Market being able to
deliver genuinely affordable properties
that would otherwise have been lost is
essential and being able to deliver them
in an area that is often harder to
access for those on Lower incomes is
incredibly important I'm more than happy
to answer any questions thank you uh
thank you Council white so members any
questions councelor
Fuki thank you very much for this um I'm
just passing on a question for one of my
residents really um I absolutely see the
need for a mix of dwellings but um some
of my residents who are squeezed into a
family squeezed into um Flats on um
Inman Avenue are asking about why there
are the the mix of the one bedroom of
the one person accommodations I was just
wondering how you have come to that um
understanding about the need for the one
for accommodation for one person if
that's all right so I can answer
them
so
so the need for one beds is
significantly higher than for Family
Properties so as Ashley was say saying
when we purchase Properties or look to
purchase Properties or look to develop
we're always looking to reflect the
percentages within the housing list so
actually our need for one beds is very
very significant we do often hear from
families who do need to expand but
actually our primary need I think at the
moment is for one bed properties thank
you members
Council thank you chair thanks
Ashen Helen could you just talk us
through the table under 2.4 where we've
got the the income and then the revenue
cost the different aspects of that could
you just tell us a little bit more about
that I'm I'm interested particularly in
the management contribution I know it's
not a large amount but I'd just like to
know what's the thing it
covers so I'll um I'll take that
question if that's okay um so obviously
we put this table together for
we're going to be doing something
similar to this for every property that
we um or every scheme that we propos
through this program um and uh it
basically it's it's a summary of the
impact on the housing revenue account
business plan of taking these properties
on um when we brought the report to full
Council um
identifying um the overall impact uh of
the 4 100 homes program um we had
assumed um that that scale of growth in
the housing portfolio would require two
extra officers to provide housing
Management Services and maintenance
services and obviously every scheme that
we then produce makes a contribution to
that um at some point we will have to
make the decision to recruit to one or
both of those roles um so far with the
numbers we've taken on so far the team
have absorbed that work uh but at some
point they won't be able to and we'll
need to recruit some extra
officers that's great Bob thank
you anyone
else Council
Bri um just a couple of questions about
the um about the builds themselves I've
got some social housing in in in my ward
that I think is relatively new and it's
not it's not count looned it's it's it's
other social housing or affordable
housing and the standard of it is pretty
shoddy um I know that this particular
development is is looks like it's a
pretty high standard um so I'm going to
ask two questions around that are we
have do we how well how closely do we
monitor the actual standard of the
builds so you know I.E you know the
walls are straight and doors fit Etc um
and also are they are they sustainable
housing have we got points in place to
to sort of f future proof Gates
sustainability
[Music]
goals um like you said this developer is
particularly a good developer and we're
confident that um you know that the the
builds will be pretty great they will
have all their uh warranties they will
be snagged by us we will do visits
throughout yeah and then when practical
completion obviously there will be a
retention as well for the follow of the
Year afterwards we can have any snagging
issues
um on the second part of your question
I'm happy to come in on that because we
have discussed putting together a
specification that reflects what we
expect of our housing and what we work
to produce so that we know that we are
requiring properties that represent the
values that we want to put forward and
the requirements that we have for our
residents so that would be part of the
program going
forward thank you anyone
else no I I have a question
actually
hello on uh 2.4 uh 2.1 it says officers
were contacted by Milwood homes um who
are required to deliver five is five the
the the development is up what it had to
be the maximum is five there or are
there other ones that they need to are
they managed to offload some and with
two shared ownership so they the whole
affordable amount is seven so they're
and they're um in partnership with Halo
housings through the shared ownership
element okay so is this is this now
going to become an issue for all
developers that are unable to offload
their affordable hous I mean obviously
we can't go around clearing up and
buying up all the houses I mean you've
got developments going on all over than
I mean if Milwood homes can't offload
their superior quality houses I mean are
other developers having this problem as
well yeah I mean personally I think it's
the the number um because today I've
heard that uh one of of the other sites
that we would potentially might need to
look at they've actually secured an RP
so um that's really positive it's a new
register provider to the area um you
know we're not going to compete with an
an RP if someone's going to take it then
but there's more units there so that's
why I think potentially the five is a
bit bit of a bit
tricky okay thank you okay members uh
we thank you J I was just wondering do
we have um a timeline of
delivery
um they are due to start on site shortly
so it'll be a 12- month build and we'll
monitor it we are in the process we're
going to be recruiting an officer that
will monitor that build as well ready
for
Handover okay thank you so members were
asked to make any recommendations to
take forward to Cabinet I presume there
aren't any so uh we're asked to note the
report so noted thank you okay moving on
to item four
she's the local Authority housing fund
round two the purchase of five homes uh
call on M Jackson again to introduce the
report thank you thank you in March 2023
it was announced that the local
Authority housing fund would be expanded
by 250 million for a second round of
funding than it has been identified as
eligible for Capital grant funding with
an indicative allocation of 694,000
funding to purchase four homes for the
resettlement element and one home for
the temporary accommodation element of
the funding in order in order to utilize
the grant it was necessary to match fund
the Acquisitions with £
78880 of borrowing within the HRA
Capital program this will be presented
to cabinet on the 16th of November the
properties have been identified and the
purchases must be complete by the 31st
of March
2024 business plan modeling shows that
the scheme generates a surplus again
from year one due to the grant subsidy
this Surplus could be used to subsidize
other parts of the affordable homes
program it is proposed to let the line
the homes in line with our T tency
strategy discussions have taken place
with a local developer currently um
developing the westw cross site to
purchase five three bed homes the units
will be off the shelf with no
refurbishment or adaptations needed
they're nearing completion and will be
ready soon the developer has accepted a
provisional officer subject to approval
of 1.4 million this is 80% of the market
value we have run this through our
business plan modeling and the scheme
generates a surplus for the h business
plan from year one The Proposal will be
presented to cabinet at its meeting on
the 16th of November and the report will
recommend that cabinet approves the use
of the
694,000 grant funding and
78880 match funding from the already
approved HRA Capital program to purchase
the five units for the local Authority
housing fund round
two thank you okay thank you members
have you got any
questions oh councilor
W thank you chair you're being very
indulgent and kind um tonight members
are being asked to consider and respond
to the proposals going forward to
Cabinet regarding the purchase of five
properties using the local government
housing Grant this is a grant that has
come before members before
we applied for and were granted 1.19
million in the first Tran of this grant
to provide homes for those who arrived
in the country via the following
approaches the Afghan citizen
resettlement scheme which includes
eligible British
Nationals the Afghan relocations and
assistance policy the Ukraine family
scheme homes for Ukraine and the Ukraine
extension
scheme in this tranch of funding we have
been granted £ 694,000
through this we intend to provide five
homes four must have at least three
bedrooms and one is required to be used
for temporary
accommodation as with the previous
trancher funding the time scales are
extraordinarily tight in order to
deliver the homes required in the period
given direct purchase is the only
realistic Way Forward as members will
know this aspect of funding frustrates
me hugely as it does limit our
creativity and provision but the net
result Remains the Same namely that we
can support those who need our support
at an incredibly difficult time for the
allotted time they are allowed to remain
by central government and not only grow
our general portfolio but also support
the growth of our housing
overall these homes are significant not
just in what they can achieve in
supporting those who have experienced
war in displacement but also in what
they can do to support other vulnerable
residents due to the scale of this Grant
and its provision of 46% of the overall
cost the rental of these properties
produces a surplus from year one as
demonstrated by the provided graph this
is especially significant as part of our
strategy as it provides a revenue scream
to not only offset borrowing to produce
the 400 plus properties that we are
producing for General usage but also to
support further housing acquisition and
production it is rare that both moral
and financial benefits align this is one
of those rare
cases life often calls on us to do the
right thing for others
this moral imperative runs through every
decision that we make as a council and
is especially pertinent here but to be
able to provide for even more residents
specifically through fulfilling our
moral duty is a circumstance that rarely
appears in local government but this
strategy allows it a huge thank you to
Ashley for all of her work on this and
we welcome any questions thank you thank
you councilor whed members any questions
you'd like to
make Council Austin it's not a question
it's really a well done everybody and
that sounds fantastic but I particularly
like the comment about the the moral and
financial aligning because you're right
it very often doesn't but it it's great
to see it happening here thank you
all councilor
B just a quick question on the um on the
placement of these homes are they
obviously they're all within the
westward development are they all sort
of clumped together or they scatter
throughout the development I'm I'm just
concerned I'm slightly concerned that um
for the residents that they might be
slightly isolated if they're all if
they're all from one specific community
and they're isolated within you know how
how well integrated are they across the
across that particular
development yeah they are all together
they're on um the section that's being
completed at the moment uh I think it's
phase three
um yeah
I when I spoke to the developer I didn't
I didn't ask to have them kind of
scattered all over the area just due to
management I think it's easier for us if
they're all together and I also think
the communities would rather be together
as well to be honest understand that is
there anything that we've got have we
got sort of I think I asked this before
actually I'm getting Deja Vu do we do we
have some sort of community liais on
that helps them sort of settle into the
kind of wide so they can be part of the
wide Community we're currently funding a
Ukrainian Support Officer um she's
actually her role is to deal with um
families who are experiencing trouble
with their housing but specifically she
will be able to support these households
and I suspect she probably already does
to be honest she has a in her not in her
rle at TDC she she she does a lot of
community work with the Ukrainian um
community so I'm sure she's
probably very well informed thank you i'
Echo Council Austin's words thank
[Music]
you Council can I just add to that that
the that the Ukrainian support officer
is somebody who is at lynchpin of the
Ukrainian community in in sanet and
Incredibly well networked so she's she's
a real treasure and a real benefit to to
the
community council
Davis uh I'd just like to say how much I
welcome the initiative um with regard to
whether the units are together or
segregated at Westwood uh I'd just like
to say that my personal experience and
and I am surrounded by um a a
particularly uh well integrated group of
working Eastern European various
nationalities they choose to live almost
communally because it gives them that
that that Network and support that and
comfort and uh we have a very
comfortable existence with them and
they're a joy to have there so I think
having them together should actually
help Bond them rather than isolate them
so anyone
else Okie doie uh so do any members have
any recommendations you want to take
forward to Cabinet I presume that's a no
so we're asked to note the report okay
so we'll ask Pacman to come back and
join us
yeah
okay moving on to item number five which
is the extension to the alcohol public
space protection order so I call on Miss
Joanna Taylor to introduce the report
welcome to the meeting thank you and
good evening everyone so we're here to
look at a 9month extension for the
public space protection order which
regulates alcohol consumption within the
district the pspo has been in place
since 2017 and it was renewed in 2020
and so it's due for Renewal again it
runs for 3
years so it was introduced to tackle
antisocial behavior and public disorder
related to alcohol consumption in public
places and this was originally requested
by Kent
Police this includes Street drinking
public intoxication and disturbances
causing caused by alcohol rated
activities the pspo has been successful
in reducing these issues and improving
the safety and well-being of the
community however during Co 19 pandemic
it has created new challenges in
ensuring compliance with the pspo with
the relaxation of lockdown measures
there has been an increase in the number
of people gathering in public places and
this has led to more incidents of
antisocial behavior and public disorder
related to alcohol consumption over the
last 3
years since January 2023 the police have
issued 23 fixed penalty notices under
the alcohol pspo this may seem a small
number and it may query the need of the
a pspo however as part of the pspo
education is also in place alcohol
confiscation and disposal of alcohol is
also in there under the powers so it can
be dealt with without the need of a
fine to address these challenges we
reest an extension of the pspo for f
than 9 months the short period of 9
months will then bring it in line with
the antisocial Behavior
pspo so in July 2024 we will look at
combining the antisocial Behavior and
the alcohol pspo and that's due the very
end of
July during this time we will continue
to monitor the effectiveness of the
order and and assess the potential for
any necessary adjustments to sure it
remains an effective tool in regulating
alcohol consumption in public
places we will also continue to work
closely with Kemp police who actually
issue the fixed penalty notices for us
and other partners to ensure consistent
enforcement of the order we are all
committed to creating a safer and
healthier Community for our residents
and visitors and we believe extending
the P
PPO will support this
thank you Miss saor uh members any
questions Council Austin as usual I was
going one of the questions I was going
to ask Joe was about numbers and you've
come up with something there about the
numbers of of notices have you got any
data about the numbers of individuals
that have been worked with during this
period because obviously if a lot of it
is education it's presumably not going
through the formal
yes process it's it's it's not going
through the formal process it um is
about Council officers and police
officers having the conversations um
what is the impact that that person's
having um they need to stop if they
don't
stop then a fine is issued majority of
the time somebody stops because they've
got a police officer in front of them
and have you got information about how
numbers of people that that have been
worked with in that way is that
TR in that sort of way they don't record
it okay okay can I ask something else um
I also wanted to ask about um supposing
that we as as counselors as individuals
are out and about and we see you know
Street drinking going on what what
action would you recommend we take um if
you see antisocial Behavior with regards
to drinking you can contact the police
just straight through the police y
straight straight through to the police
can issue the fines count some Council
officers can Al also issue fines um but
then it's about availability coming out
at that time so You' recommend straight
yesk Council
cup thank you chair um good
evening so on um it's it's one of the
options uh for the recommendation is to
delegate any minor movment of the pspo
to the chief exec so what would normally
be class as a minor Amendment and also
sorry I know it's very technical sorry
and and do you know of any uh minor
amendments that have been put into place
since it's uh came in at 2017 at
all no minor Amendments have been done
since it originally came came in um when
we say minor amendments it may be slight
changes on
locations um it's really difficult one
to say because this one covers it's
districtwide um and it's quite a basic
pspo so the likelihood of Minor
Adjustments would be extremely
slim councilor Mo yes thank you chair
and thank you J for your report um we
just alluded to contacting the police
that's on a 101 or a 999 call
101 unless sorry unless it's an absolute
emergency need someone there straight
away then
999 councelor
fi thank you um I've lost counted the
number of um 15year olds I have come
into A&E who've kind of collapsed had
needed CT scans CU I found them kind of
they've been found passed out or have
seizures or alcohol related issues after
a night out do the fixed penalty notices
also um are are they also applicable to
underage drinkers how are we working
with those um people because I've those
are the ones I've seen who've actually
come in with um medical emergencies for
example um if we're aware if they're
coming in for medical emergencies then
no we wouldn't it has to be linked to um
antisocial Behavior or the or we think
antisocial behavior is is going to
happen um we don't like finding somebody
who's under the age of 18
um we find other Roots we find other
Roots we we can give a a um Community
protection warning we can speak to
parents um but asking somebody who's
under 18 to pay a
fine is probably not something they're
going going to pay so we do go down
other routes um but we wouldn't find
somebody just for underage drinking
understood and I'm not I'm actually
talking about someone who's actually
been unwell but in that peer group that
they're in because that's you know those
are the ones who have gone out and then
sort of abandoned their friend in the
middle of the street and kind of
staggered home so how is there any way
of approaching those or you just it it
doesn't really
apply we would approach it in other ways
um if if we know there's a problem in a
certain area with underage drinkers then
we would approach it in different ways
we would look at um Youth Services
Outreach workers um if it was a
significant problem ongoing we may um
might we definitely speak to parents we
would look at enforcement action we
would look at court action if it became
a continued problem so we go down lots
of different different
Roots councilor
Davis uh very much welcome your um
extension to the uh to the order Joanna
a couple of questions because obviously
the pspo hopefully is having an impact
and it's not necessarily about the
number of tickets issued it's about how
many people have been dissuaded perhaps
by the chance of a ticket or indeed have
agreed to pour their drink away cuz
because I've witnessed that plenty of
times and I don't know if that's ever
logged as a statistic and probably isn't
so but clearly the the system works but
enforcement resources as ever are
probably the issue because there's
hotpots in I mean listening to uh
councelor farooqi the issues in
broadstairs clearly a little bit
different to say in Ramsgate Town Center
where there are hotpots where
the hardcore Street drinkers keep
gravitating keep you know it's
antisocial behavior however you choose
to color it firstly do you think this
sit situation will be better served
because we've moved away from the PPO
model and now got beat officers with
warrant cards who can probably enforce
this better uh than the previous uh
model and um also given that a lot of
the time the issues are in in uh public
areas the small Parks or Courtyards and
also Town Center uh given the identity
is well known of some of the individuals
that are repeat offenders all the time
would CCTV count as evidence to to take
action an issue and with
a fine sorry that's fine um I'll cover
your first one first um is a lot easier
having the beat officers there um they
do get to know the IND individual people
as well um they get to know the area
they get to know the hotpots um having
beat officers there um is an awful lot
more effective um for the location but
also us as officers as well um rather
than having the real
mix um with regards the second point and
CCTV um I'd have to speak to Eden about
the CCTV and can it be collected as
evidence I believe it can um but when it
comes to issuing a notice the person
who's issuing the notice has to directly
see the behavior in front of
them difficult I know
yeah thank you chair okay thanks anybody
else can I can I just ask a question M
uh on 2.2 says the council continues to
receive a number of complaints are these
any particular areas or you know the
regular areas that we know of or is it
just sporadic across the area
um it is a mixture of areas I think we
probably know them um we obviously have
um
Margate um we have Rams gate and um
board stairs is also on the
raadar do do we do anything to try and
mitigate the the issues maybe if it's
somewhere they congregate with benches
like removing benches to stop that sort
of behavior or is it is it just too many
areas to deal with um there is an awful
lot of areas
designing out crime is a big element of
reducing antisocial behavior and we do
work with open spaces and minor minor
works with regards hotspot areas can we
remove shelters can we remove benches or
not completely remove them or just move
them down the road you know do we chop
back a tree because it's getting in the
way of CCTV so there's lots of little
things we can do when we design out clim
thank you okay members we're asked uh to
make any recommendations to Cabinet I
presume that's uh no so uh if we're
asked to note the report okay and that
concludes the business for tonight's
meeting thank you members for coming
along thank you to officers and cabinet
members thank
you